[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Chris Long Inside the NFL
analyst and former NFL defensive end won
a Super Bowl uh what did you want a
couple of Super Bowls didn't you did you
win the Patriots and Eagles got a little
lucky at the end there Dan okay yeah
where are the Rings good to see you uh
the Rings are in a safe you know the
Rings are like they're only for team
events you know like uh NFL Honors that
sort of thing
I'm the type that would lose my Super
Bowl ring so they stay in the safe this
is what I proposed years ago that we
should have a ring and then inside the
ring like you can wear it almost like a
class ring from high school yeah so it's
medium size it's not gaudy but it still
represents something you did with your
team then you're gonna lay out the show
ring if you want to but this gives you
the hey there's my high school
graduation ring I kind of like that I'd
like to have four rings you know feel
like Robert orey or one of these guys
that stacked a bunch of them up but yeah
yeah I got lucky there at the end Dan it
was it was a good little run good to
talk to you again what's it like being
on a bad team
wow the hard-hitting questions right off
the bat it's so funny Dan I I was
watching it's not funny not for the
people of Chicago but I was watching the
Bears and you know that game against
Tampa I feel like I've been in that game
a hundred times in eight years in St
Louis I mean one in 15 2 and 14. you
know the height of our our run there was
seven and nine
um and that that Chicago team feels a
lot like teams that I was on you know
when you you gather a little bit of Hope
you go through camp and Camp is tough
because you got these old vets and
especially when I got in the league it
was the old CBA so you had a bunch of
old guys who had seen it all you know
they were a little bit hardened and they
were going to be honest with you about
how the team looked today I think in
Camp it's all feel good everybody's got
hope it's a bunch of young players you
don't know in Camp if you've only been
in for like four years if your team
sucks and back in the day I think we had
a pretty good pulse on that so it was
like a mind game you know as the years
went on of how can I trick myself into
believing that we have a shot to do this
and the hardest part is it's not like
the NBA it's not like the MLB when
you're gonna you're gonna suck you get
on the team plane you go to dinner you
have fun on the road I'm not saying
these guys are having fun when they're
winning 20 games in the NBA but it's a
lot easier
then an NFL player is going to put his
body on the line every Sunday and
knowing that like if you turn on your TV
and you're an Arizona Cardinal you're
drafting Caleb Williams according to
guys like myself and everybody else and
sometimes I think we make it a little
bit too simple when it comes to like
punting on a season so it can be really
hard every Sunday it's like taking the
field and knowing we're probably going
to lose but you got to go out there and
kind of I don't know you hope to be the
guy that jumps off the tape if anybody's
watching you know because nobody's
watching on TV but somebody's going to
be watching next week in the all 22 if
anybody's watching if anybody cares I'm
going to be the guy that jumps off the
tape what did you see in the Minka
Fitzpatrick hit on Nick Chubb so at
first Dan you know because it's all slow
motion in in the and I heard your take
that you know they should have showed it
um that stuff doesn't doesn't bother me
because you know like listen it's
happened to my friends I've seen it in
person it's hard to make me squeamish
but they do show the slow motion they
don't go full speed the angle was kind
of from the right sideline so you don't
see minka's Approach at full speed and
initially even as a defensive player who
albeits saw the game from the front and
never had to make those plays okay
uh I was like hey man people are saying
Minka has a track record he's just doing
it he's going for it he's just going low
and he's got to know that linebacker's
there but uh as I slept on it and I woke
up to do inside the NFL and Ryan Clark
was there and I was reading through his
Twitter and he's going back and forth
with Nate Burleson I'm kind of like do I
disagree with the host here
you know uh me and Ryan didn't talk
about it but I just got on all 22 and
and took a closer look and I do not
think it was dirty and the thing that
because for you to prove that
something's dirty it has to be uh with
malicious intent intent to injure
um you can say that it's an imperfect
situation for running backs in the NFL
we talk about this all the time I mean
it's a tough job and this is why you can
say that it's tough for Defenders you
know they've legislated where you can
hit a guy the whole thing but I think
the the most compelling argument for me
is I'm texting guys and calling guys
that I play with on the back end who are
the furthest thing from Dirty players
people that I respect greatly and
they're like listen man not dirty at all
it's the four yard line we got to get
this guy down he's not seeing that
backer who almost simultaneously jumps
on chub's back I saw comparisons to a
defensive lineman being high load not
true I mean a defensive lineman being
high-lowed in today's game is it's
vindictive that's the only way you high
low somebody I mean it's so easy to hurt
somebody doing that even back in my
dad's day he used to tell me about hey
when the the 290 pound guards were
getting thrown around by He-Man out
there and they were tired of Howie Long
they would high low him and it was a
dirt bag thing to do now
the difference is this when a running
back is churning his feet statistically
speaking it's really hard to to hit that
guy at the right time and injure him
even if you were trying because his feet
are up and down if you're if you're
anchoring in a four technique both your
feet are planted you're stationary and
there's no expectation of that happening
guys guys do this all the time I watch
the tape 23 because he for the for the
Steelers made a play at the beginning of
the fourth quarter early in the game it
happened a couple times in that game
alone so I'm just not comfortable
calling a guy dirty you know that's a
heavy accusation I've seen dirty plays
you want to talk about dirty go back to
college football landscape last week
it's not worth death threats I think
that thing was ridiculous I think I
heard you all talking about Dion I think
he's just been brilliant at the podium
the voice of reason the adult in the
room but this was not a dirty play on
Monday night in my opinion and it took
me a second I'll admit and today I think
the landscape is when you get online you
get on X you get on the X machine
you're so afraid to step out and say hey
guys I don't see it that way because
you know the compounding effect of
everybody's opinion is the people who
know will be afraid to be called that
same thing and it's not worth them to
speak up and I learned that in reaching
out to a few DBS and a wide receiver who
said the same thing
we're talking to Chris Long Inside the
NFL the hostess Ryan Clark Channing
Crowders there Jay Cutler Ochocinco
every Tuesday at 8 Eastern on the CW and
stream the episode the next day on
cwtv.com and the CWU app is there
anybody that you still Harbor a grudge
against that you played against
not really I was talking about this the
other day you know there was a guy named
Anthony Davis in San Francisco and we
outwardly didn't like each other you
know he was younger I got the best of
him a few times and I'm sure somewhere
he's sitting there uh with his feet
kicked up like you bringing this up
again I'm good you know like uh you know
it was really hard for me breno
giacomini a guy who played Ned Tom Cable
offense in Seattle and it was so
physical and he'd hit you late
and he'd dump you and that group would
do borderline dirty stuff but for the
most part when I got off the field and I
was done I was done with it
um it takes a lot to Harbor a grudge
like that my grudge is more against
teams that we just couldn't seem to beat
you know and I try not to let it affect
my analysis and I think I've done a
pretty good job of it because I picked
the San Francisco 49ers to be in the
Super Bowl I've been complimentary of
the of the Seahawks the thing that I've
had the hardest time with Dan and maybe
you could help me out is fan bases are
extremely sensitive about their teams
and they think it's personal and you
know like I'll be breaking down the
Falcons and I'll be like hey they're a
good team Desmond Ritter has to catch up
and I got a hundred Falcons fans in my
mentions like you know you're a hater
you hate us I don't hate you
um why do you read them why do you read
them because we're a a growing podcast
so at this point you know you're Dan
Patrick you know like you don't need to
read your comments you don't need
feedback your show's been going don't
let them change your opinion
Desmond Ritter needs to catch up I'm
saying it again The Dan Patrick Show but
I like to read because you know
sometimes the comments are actually
constructive they're like we like this
we need time stamps on the YouTube video
maybe more of this why didn't you talk
about the Cardinals today well why don't
you have somebody who goes through have
you that's a good idea or your wife goes
through
and and no you don't want your wife no
but have somebody who goes through it
and then filters and just says hey
here's thing this is what the donets do
congratulations Matt in the back of the
room one of our producers here I don't
have a cool name promoting like the Dan
that's yeah Matt you get to go through
all the YouTube missions and aggregate
the opinions yeah there you go Matt
congratulations Matt just got promoted
what's your name Patrick what's your
story that you're going to tell your uh
kids about Tom Brady
a few I think you know the first and
foremost uh I got a lot of respect for
the guy you know like I'm not just
saying that I don't have to well don't
give us any cheesy Stuff no I've been
critical of him when when he's you know
ninja kicked defensive backs after
interceptions like you know I don't know
if it's a New England quarterback thing
with Mac Jones and him where they
they're a little bit but I think Tom
Brady was one of the nicest most
down-to-earth teammates I had and I I
truly think he's a good person he has a
good heart uh and when I got into New
England somebody's a leader on a team
like that it can be really good or it
can be really disruptive because
you're good players they set the tone
and if it's not a great guy you know
that can that can that can kind of
poison a locker room even if you don't
realize it when I walked into the
building you know I'd played nine years
uh on a lot of bad teams had had a good
run but I didn't expect that Tom Brady
knew much about me and you know of
course I walk in he's passing me in the
hallway we're on the way out to walk
through and I I say Tom nice to meet you
I'm Chris you know appreciate you
um and he goes and he's actually I was
coming up to introduce myself Chris I
just wanted to welcome you here you know
I've enjoyed watching you play we're
happy to have you and I saw him repeat
that interaction with four or five guys
that were new kind of Veteran additions
in that locker room I saw him treat the
janitor the same way that he'd treat you
know Bill I saw him treat the guy in the
parking lot the same way that he would
treat uh Josh McDaniels I really do
believe you can judge somebody on how
they treat the person in the building
who you need the lease from and I saw
him on many occasions do that and I also
saw him turn into
uh Hell on Wheels on the sideline which
you need to be sometimes and I think
some people see him slamming a tablet
and they want to point the finger at him
and say you know bad teammate or
whatever that's leadership sometimes and
you can say it's not the the packaging
you like or he looks like a baby
sometimes but sometimes you got to be
that guy and I thought he possessed the
the ability to do both be that picky up
guy have fun but also the guy could jump
down your throat and strike the fear of
God and the wide receivers but then you
have Belichick
doesn't say too much nah
nah Chris that's uh good to see you yeah
good game
I love bill I love Bill Dad I I I I
can't help but love Bill how do you love
Bill there what do you what's there to
love a lot the guys got hobbies that are
like quirky he likes like uh boats and
Lacrosse and you know like he likes his
dog it's just kind of like disarming
that the dude who you know you thought
for a long time was maybe Darth Vader
has this kind of soft side and if you
get Bill to laugh
I mean you just it I used to go through
the hall and just try to make Bill laugh
you know not in a kissing up way but I
just wanted to see him smile because you
know when he just breaks character for a
second that upper lip moves just a
little bit and you're like hey we did it
yeah you used to love Yeah like we used
to love that but I you know I love bill
because he was honest and so many
coaches in the NFL will not shoot you
straight even if they're gonna fire you
in two weeks they'll they'll be afraid
to tell you that to your face
in their office I had two coaches like
that I remember when I was when I was
unhealthy at the end of my career in St
Louis Greg Williams pulled me in his
office and I was like Hey I want to be
out there on third down and I'm thinking
in my head like a competitor and he's
like you're not good enough right now
you're not healthy enough I love you but
that's a disservice to the other guys
and and it took that it took hearing the
honesty and the same thing with Bill you
know being honest with me at different
turns in the road uh and another thing I
love about Bill is this Dan it's a
little bit off the beaten path for a fam
but when we travel as NFL players
whether you're a 10-year vet a 14-year
vet a rookie chances are these coaches
are going to put you back in coach
ironically uh and the coaches the little
510 guys well I don't want to say five
ten maybe the five seven guys some of
the quality control guys the little feet
are kicking you know above the ground
they don't need all that leg room uh and
they're up there watching all 22 having
a soda and we're in the back and we just
played 60 plays and I'm cramped between
Jordan milotta and Lane Johnson okay but
when we were in New England Bill put all
the guys that he could up in the front
Bill Saturn coach so you know you think
about that's just a little anecdote
about the guy
um I I loved his honesty I love the fact
that he respected his players and uh and
I've texted him since and you think I
was just there for a year played a role
um left in free agency maybe you know
maybe he'd be happy about that or maybe
he'd hold a grudge uh but he's actually
you know we've talked from time to time
and one time I complimented him on that
very travel deal and I got a text out of
the blue from Bill that was like I
appreciate you commending our travel
Chris and I just made my day I just I'm
a big Bill fan and yeah you can say the
Personnel decisions haven't been great
but I really think there's a good
football team in there and I would
almost go as far as saying that's the
best 0-2 team in the league if that's
the distinction you want to own
good luck with Inside the NFL my best of
the family as always and thanks for
joining us thanks Dan great to see you
that's Chris Long Inside the NFL analyst
and you can watch every Tuesday at 8
Eastern on the CW stream the episode the
next day on cwtv.com and the cwm